we're told that katie made a table to
show how much time she spent on homework
last week and so we can see the
different subjects and then how much she
spent
in terms of hours so on math she spent
three fourths of an hour reading 7 8 of
an hour writing 3 6 of an hour and then
signs 5 10 of an hour and then they ask
us on which activities did katie spend
more than two-thirds of an hour so pause
this video and see if you can figure
that
out all right so we essentially have to
figure out which of these fractions are
greater than two-thirds of an hour or
which are greater than two-thirds and
this is all in terms of hours
so first let's just think about
representing two-thirds so let me do it
like this and i'm going to hand draw it
so it's not going to be perfect
but if this is a hole
right over here
i could split it into three equal
sections so i'm going to try to do that
let me see does that look about right
so three equal sections so that would be
a third that would be a third and then
that would be a third and then
two-thirds would be two of them
so i'll pick these first two well it
doesn't have to be those first two so
that's one third
and then two thirds
so let's see if we can draw a similar
visual for each of these
so what about three fourths so once
again let's make
this a whole
and now if i'm going to think in terms
of fourths i have to divide into four
equal sections so let's see if i divide
it that'll be two equal sections and
then i could divide each of those into
two equal sections so let's see maybe
something like this
and then like
this
so it's hand drawn but these are four
equal sections and so this would be a
fourth that would be a fourth and that
would be a fourth and that would be a
fourth four fourths make a hole so three
of those fourths would be
one
two
and then three and so you can see and
i've drawn it pretty close it's not
perfect because it's hand drawn but you
can see that three-fourths is more of a
whole than two-thirds it's greater than
two-thirds so katie spent more than
two-thirds of an hour on math because
three-fourths is greater than two-thirds
so i like
this one right over there i'll just put
a square circle around the ones that she
spent that extra time on or the more the
greater than two thirds of an hour on
now let's think about reading 7 8.
so to compare that i will once again
make a hole here
and then i want to think about 7 8. so
i'm going to split into eight equal
sections so let's see that will split
into two equal sections and then then i
can go to
four equals sections
and then if i split each of those into
two
this would be eight equal sections so it
looks something
like
this
not perfect but i think it will get the
job done
so each of these are an eighth so seven
eighths are going to be
one
two
three four
five
six and seven eighths clearly once again
greater than our two-thirds that we have
in purple so she spent
more than two-thirds of an hour on
reading now what about writing three
sixths
what would that look like
well i'll do another one right over here
so if that is a hole
well actually let me split into thirds
first since we already have a bit of a
reference there we can look up there and
we can see
those are thirds and if we split each of
those into two we're going to have six
because we'll have six equal sections
so
it would look something like
that
and then three of those six well that's
one
two
and three so we can see that 3 6 is less
than two-thirds so i'm not going to
circle that one she didn't spend more
than two-thirds of an hour on writing
and then last but not least
science
five-tenths
well once again
we can make a hole here
and let's see i want to do into 10 equal
sections so
that's two equal sections then each of
these i can do in the five equal
sections let's see
one
two
three
four
five i can do a little bit neater than
that three
four and five and then
one
two
three
four and
five i can make it a little bit neater
but i think this will get us to where we
need to get to so these are each a tenth
i could write 1 10
1 10. i could do that for all 10 of
these but we care about five of these
tenths so one
two
three
four
five of those tenths and notice five
tenths is the exact same thing as 3 6
and like 36 it is less than two-thirds
so which activities did katie spend more
than two-thirds of an hour on clearly
math and reading